i'm ryan right hey I'm Jerry what's up
these are our personation we're gonna
watch a clip of Fifty Shades of Grey so
excited I bought the book about a month
ago I've only read about 58 pages
I need a hurry up before this movie
comes out I'll do a chapter by chapter
review for you guys oh boy yeah I'm sure
you guys emails I secretly hope this
movie's incredible and I don't know why
dude I hope we get like awesome BJ's in
this film I thought it was you what a
pleasant surprise for still you're in
here I was an area business needed to
pick up a few things be free yeah can I
help you do you start cable ties yes I
do making sure you please get the waiver
still just in
best damn baby decorating likes give a
[ __ ] yes
[ __ ] I see what he's doing here is
impressive so what is your thing you're
the complete serial good I can't wait to
like this oh it's gonna be a good time
you've been in it sucks it's gonna be
worried if the thing is I actually like
her and I don't know what their
chemistry is because that was a very
strange scene I'm not in the way it's
supposed to be awkward like well it's
supposed to be awkward because she's
like the total version or some [ __ ] I
know and then she thinks Christian
Grey's like [ __ ] this is a beautiful
thing yeah it's yeah it's Twilight I
love it like the acting sounds like
they're totally reading from the script
they sound like they really prepare
their lines beforehand I thought she did
a good job on that scene I mean yeah
that opening gasp was great the way they
edited that though is a little bit
awkward like that I thought it was you
here's what I wanted when I saw Twilight
if I walk away from this film like in
the guy
Edward yeah I think I'd be a-okay this
guy I'm like doesn't look like anything
special right now he just seems weird
and he doesn't seem like he's in the
moment with me the thing is in this
scene I can tell what her note was and
what his note yeah they're clearly
supposed to be feeling two very
different things and it's like they're
supposed to be kind of not having a
battle but it's like you know they're
they're two very conflicting emotions
playing off each other and I can feel
that direction the holds you know what
the word we're looking for that is not
present chemistry well you the chemistry
is weird in this scene this scene their
chemistry is weird to me and not in the
way it's supposed yeah yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't make me go oh yeah these actors
are gonna be [ __ ] awesome yet the
other can't wait for them to get
together yeah can't wait for them but
the thing is like between her and
Kristen Stewart I almost wish that they
put her in Twilight she seems like she
can do the brand of like shy awkward
that won't be annoying she's shy and
awkward but she's trying not to be shy
and awkward
whereas Kristen Stewart while it has
this sort of I feel like every line she
speaks should be followed by you look I
actually from reading the book I kind of
get what this dude is going for with
this role but at the same time I'm like
no I imagine someone who's way more like
[ __ ] this should have got him Ryan
Gosling we need to stop either writing
books or just adapting books where like
the character description is like this
man doesn't exist he's impossibly
gorgeous and impossibly charismatic he's
so sublime that to perceive him with the
naked eye is to ascend into Valhalla
like don't do it because no dude will
ever be that good I still think it's
shot well this yeah I mean like the
cinematography yeah he's like I was in
the area business needed to pick up a
few things it sounds like he's trying
not to slip into his relaxing it sounds
like a dramatic reading of just because
like he's more of an affluent
about town and she is but I just get
this no that's what I mean it's like I
feel like they're playing notes yeah
especially him I feel like he's playing
like a note I feel like he's not
actually living this character I feel
like he is following his directions
you know perhaps and I mean it's always
hard to tell from one scene I mean I buy
a genuinely by her and flustered right
now but that was like a minute and a
half yeah that's enough to give you
enough like this isn't like a 20-second
clip like a minute and a half is enough
to kind of give you a little I mean I
know the relationship is supposed to
develop over time but know what I'm
saying like it's a taste of it like it
doesn't give me the greatest hope for
how the rest of the movie will play out
but I'm saying sometimes you know a
movie starts and then it hits a stride
you're like ah cuz you got to be there
for 10 15 minutes before you can really
I feel like he's trying to be Michael C
Hall from Dexter but is not pulling it
off like the charm is supposed to be
kind of similar to Dexter of a guy who's
is really charming and lovable but he
has this other dark secret and that's
his thing to his other dark secret yeah
seems a fake to me
it's nothing it doesn't seem real and it
doesn't make me want to watch the movie
any less though yeah I am so there
opening night this looks like a blast
I'll probably end up at a matinee on a
Friday oh come on this is so fun you're
gonna have a good time it's it's rated R
for like the strong graphic stuff in it
yeah so it's like okay it's even if it
sucks it's gonna be fun
so apparently I read an article just
yesterday that said like 'hey-- L James
was really upset like she wants to be
nc-17 she was like man like I'm really
upset that only 20% of the movie is sex
or whatever and I'm like dude well yeah
I hear a big I hear it is like just in a
ride for maybe the first time where a
porno is actually closer to the like the
inevitable porn parody will be closer to
the book than the movie temptation oh
dude I can't wait to watch the porn
parody happen anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects can
and we provide authenticity you could
check out reasons to Gerry his movie
review show and shoutouts will continue
but 18 to you versus a [ __ ] my internet
stellata so I'll have to go to Starbucks
and upload this video for you guys but I
can't load the shoutouts right now so go
to facebook.com slash the real reject
shadow treat and earn yourself a shadow
by saying something interesting like did
you know that Jerry's balls actually
consists of three testicles there's
really no which one of you knows that
and why I know that yeah it would make
sense for you though moving the three
balls it's like total recalls set of
titties it's balls yeah some women are
into it so no three balls apparently
yeah someone is aroused by it reasons to
Jerry is three bubbles